permettez-moi d'abord de vous dire
combien je suis honoré d'exposer devant
vous le projet que je porte au service
de public sénat et de son rayonnement en
tant que journaliste politique depuis
près de 20 ans j'ai notamment été en
charge de l'actualité parlementaire
j'ai donc pu mesurer de près la qualité
de vos travaux dans vos rapports dans
vos débats en séance ou en commission
mais j'ai aussi pu voir les exigences
d'une institution indépendante
transparente une institution qui cherche
toujours à conjuguer l'intelligence du
temps long avec cette du terrain et la
chaîne public sénat doit en être le
reflet par ailleurs mon projet vous
invite aussi à regarder le rôle la place
la responsabilité de public sénat
dans le contexte médiatique et des mots
4 et démocratique actuel selon un récent
sondage
aujourd'hui un français sur trois ne
considère plus la démocratie comme le
meilleur système un sur deux croit à
l'existence des illuminati ou encore
d'un complot sioniste mondiale fort de
ces constats
je vous propose de positionner
logiquement public sénat non pas comme
la chaîne des questions à toutes vos
réponses
selon le slogan actuelle je vous propose
de faire de public sénat la chaîne de la
confiance au service de votre actualité
parlementaire ici au palais du
luxembourg
et bien entendu sur le terrain dans vos
dés dans vos collectivités pour bâtir
cette offre
j'ai beaucoup regardé antenne consulter
des personnes de tous horizons et
écoutez je me suis appuyé sur mon
expérience car les chaînes d'information
ont démontré ces dernières années leur
utilité auprès du grand public et leurs
capacités aussi à innover dans le
traitement des sujets d'actualité public
sénat depuis ses débuts sous l'impulsion
de jean pierre elkabbach et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui sous la direction d'emmanuel
kessler a mené de nombreux chantiers
j'ai la conviction qu'il est aujourd'hui
possible nécessaire même pour public
sénat de renforcer la qualité de son
offre tout en élargissant son audience
public sénat à 20 ans un âge où il est
permis d'être ambitieux audacieux et
agile un exemple parmi d'autres les
médias qui traitent de l'actualité
politique n'ont pas toujours le temps ni
les moyens d'envoyer une équipe ici au
sénat suivre vos travaux dans
l'hémicycle ou en commission
je propose que des vidéos prête à
diffuser tournés par des journalistes de
public sénat soit mise à disposition des
autres rédactions gracieusement un
rayonnement à peu de frais bruts par
exemple a parfaitement su le faire on
source en est on si gland ses contenus
largement repris cet exemple est le
reflet de mon projet je veux faire en
sorte que votre travail soit visible au
delà du seul canal 13 de la tnt
pourquoi se priver de la force d'autres
déclinaisons d'autres supports il ya des
partenaires que l'on connaît qui relaie
vos travaux et les travaux de public
sénat facebook twitter twitch mais il ya
aussi des collaborations à imaginer
demain avec par exemple
linkedin netflix tous ces réseaux font
l'événement en mettant à disposition de
plus en plus de contenus d'information
des interviews des débats pour leurs
dizaines de millions d'abonnés en france
votre actualité les intéressent et fait
écho aux attentes des français vous
recevez ici des chefs d'entreprise des
partenaires sociaux la société civile
des représentants d'institutions clair
et donc par exemple défenseur des droits
et est auditionné demain devant la
commission des lois les libertés
publiques
une thématique forte vous le savez qui
fait l'actualité
autre point fondamental la fidélité des
équipes à la chaîne c'est une chance je
le crois il faut s'appuyer et
capitaliser sur cette force
j'entends être à l'écouté de tous les
collaborateurs particulièrement dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire
alors que les mesures de télétravail
peuvent éloigner certains salariés
j'estime aussi que la gouvernance de
l'entreprise doit se faire avec vous
public sénat
n'avez vous dis peut parfois vous
semblait éloigner de votre quotidien ou
de votre agenda
à nous de créer ce lien plus direct pour
que vos informations
votre actualité soit d'abord traité sur
public sénat
mieux valoriser et mieux reprises ce
management par le dialogue doit se faire
naturellement dans le cadre d'une
exemplarité de la chaîne s'agissant de
sa politique des ressources humaines et
de sa gestion financière
au delà de ma formation en école de
commerce j'ai durant mon parcours
professionnel travailler dans un univers
audiovisuel concurrentiel avec une
rigueur budgétaire au centre de tout je
sais aussi que cela peut être une source
de créativité
quand on s'appuie sur la technologie je
pense par exemple à l'utilisation de
smartphones pour les tournages qui se
généralise dans les médias dans le monde
entier concernant le lien avec la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale
il est aujourd'hui je crois clair pour
tout le monde une mutualisation de
moyens quand cela est nécessaire mais
pas de fusion des entités ni des
rédactions
autre axe de mon projet je veux faire de
public sénat la chaîne de la citoyenneté
celle du civisme de la défense de la
laïcité de la lutte contre la
désinformation et les théories du
complot j'entends ouvrir un kiosque
digitale de ressources pédagogiques sur
votre travail accessible prioritairement
aux jeunes publics aux enseignants cet
espace pourrait être baptisée public
sénat 100% campus je n'invente rien cela
existe aux états unis avec le module de
la chaîne parlementaire américaine
sispann classroom autre proposition les
journalistes de public sénat sont chaque
semaine sur le terrain ils peuvent en
profiter pour rencontrer des classes et
faire de l'éducation aux médias
la vérification d'informations la lutte
contre le club le complotisme prend une
place de plus en plus importante
je peux créer un pôle dédié à cela est
une déclinaison à l'antenne c'est une
priorité de ces prochaines années
on s'en rendra compte dans les prochains
mois notamment à l'occasion de la
campagne président
je propose aussi de relancer un rendez
vous d'information en direct
en deuxième partie de soirée à 22 heures
il existait dans le passé quand il était
animé par sonia mabrouk un rendez-vous
au sein duquel les partenaires de la
presse locale aurait toute leur place
pour présenter l'actualité notamment
celle du lendemain
un temps d'avancé aussi sur public sénat
j'estime également opportun de
programmer la grande émission politique
hebdomadaire le dimanche quand les
français ont le temps pour regarder ce
type de rendez vous public sénat a 20
ans et ne doit avoir aucun complexe
vis-à-vis de ses concurrents
enfin la singularité de public sénat
passe nécessairement par un traitement
de votre actualité dans vos départements
le nombre de tournages a été réduit ces
dernières années je recommande qui leur
prennent une place plus conséquente à
l'antenne surtout dans un contexte de
campagne électorale
il convient de profiter du maillage
unique des partenaires de la presse
locale en sachant mieux valoriser peut
être mieux événementialité cette
production et je tiens aussi à parler
d'europe
cette actualité aujourd'hui est traité
depuis bruxelles mais elle doit l'être
aussi je pense sur le terrain je propose
un rendez-vous qui s'appellerait
l'europe près de chez moi
la stratégie numérique et le dernier axe
de ma présentation elle doit résolument
être amplifiées dynamiser pour la
réussir public sénat doit parler
plusieurs langues
les codes d'instagram de twitter de
twitch de global où ce ne sont pas les
mêmes il faut faire des choix éditoriaux
et proposer du contenu dédié pour mieux
toucher chacune de ces communautés
il convient de repenser l'offre du site
internet
est ce utile pertinent d'avoir 9060
vidéos archivées
aujourd'hui et 55 mille articles rendant
fastidieux d'ailleurs la recherche
il faut à mon sens aujourd'hui être plus
sélectifs offensif aussi sur ce que l'on
appelle le preview ce sont des
programmes accessibles en ligne
en amont de leur diffusion par exemple
sur le canal 13 de la tnt pour faire
l'événement est aussi pour créer du lien
avec la communauté de public sénat
ce lien passe aussi par la création
d'une série de podcasts signé public
sénat un nouveau format audio plus long
permettant l'approfondissement
le premier sujet pourrait par exemple
traiter de l'actualité en nouvelle
calédonie et de l'avenir institutionnel
de ce territoire un mot pour conclure
public sénat le canal 13 de la tnt doit
demeurer vous l'avez compris le vaisseau
amiral mais public sénat doit être plus
que cela
public sénat doit être un média
conquérant qui se décline et se déploie
avec force ambitions et agilité une
chaîne attentive à son public
ancré dans tous les territoires à votre
écoute une chaîne qui conjugue qualité
de l'information diversité et pluralité
des débats publics sénat doit être la
chaîne de la confiance
voilà la route si beaucoup et ce fleurot
et nous enchaînons sans attendre donc
avec la sous quels sont les principaux
enjeux et des filles de public sénat et
dans le paysage audiovisuel actuelle
comment définiriez-vous ses missions
intrinsèque
qu'est ce qui la différencie des autres
chaînes en particulier les chaînes
d'information mais aussi lcp assemblée
nationale public sénat
je voulais dit effectivement doit parler
plusieurs langues et se déployait sur
plusieurs supports
aujourd'hui public sénat concentre ses
moyens sur le canal 13 de la tnt
je pense qu'il est important de
conserver ce mode de diffusion et j'en
fait mention dans mon rapport mais
public sénat doit se montrer plus
offensif et plus habile dans des
collaborations avec d'autres supports
je pense par exemple à certains réseaux
sociaux je pense par exemple à des
plateformes qui aujourd'hui se lance et
propose du contenu parfois plus ciblées
par exemple des plateformes qui propose
des documentaires
il faut bien densifier ses partenariats
afin que l'image de public sénat qui est
aujourd'hui bien reconnu des français
bien puisse toucher un plus large public
vous l'avez vu dans mon dossier public
c'est là et c'est peut-être ce qui peut
la démarquer des chaînes d'information
et bien c'est l'enjeu sur la citoyenneté
l'enjeu sur la démocratie
je pense que public sénat doit s'ouvrir
doit s'ouvrir aux français et plus
particulièrement au jeune public
c'est pour cette raison que je propose
la création d'un kiosque digital avec
des modules expliquant de façon très
pédagogique votre travail et vous
pourriez être acteur de ce kiosque vos
collaborateurs les journalistes de
public sénat
également je pense aussi que public
sénat doit aller à la rencontre de son
public
et cela passe notamment peut-être par
ses interventions dans des
établissements scolaires ou les
journalistes de public sénat viendrait
expliquer leur métier le journalisme
politique pour lutter contre l' les
fakes news la désinformation mais
également pour parler de votre
institution le sénat merci je donne la
parole à madame eustache brinio pour la
deuxième question oui alors vous avez
abordé légèrement ce sujet mais je
voulais vous demander si vous pensez
qu'il fallait effectivement faire
évoluer les modalités diffusion de
public sénat sur la tnt je pense que
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien qu'on
revienne sur ce sujet et si oui à
quelles conditions et surtout à quel
horizon faudrait-il le fer avec quels
modes alternatifs de diffusion à
privilégier je pense que c'est important
aujourd'hui à des innovations à faire
évidemment avec un objectif à la fois de
diversification et de renforcement de
l'audience de la chaîne
je pense que le mode de diffusion liée à
la tnt est un mode de diffusion à
conserver il représente un coût
important certes mais aujourd'hui un peu
plus de 22 % des foyers c'est un chiffre
qui date du premier semestre 2020 non
que ce seul mode de réception et je ne
recommande pas de s'en priver
parce que c'est un mode de réception
important qui de plus est de surcroît
est gratuit pour les personnes qui
regardent la télévision par ce biais
public sénat doit rester accessible au
plus grand nombre mais ne doit pas se
priver de décliner ses contenus les
productions de public sénat sur toute
une série de supports et là je pense
qu'il faut être offensif agile aussi je
vous ai parlé de plateformes vidéo qui
propose des par exemple des
documentaires du reportage
je vous parle bien entendu des réseaux
sociaux qui diffusent de plus en plus de
contenu en direct ou en différé
et je vous ai parlé du réseau par
exemple d'une caudines qu'ils
recherchent
ici par exemple quand vous recevez dans
le cadre de commissions
bien des personnalités il pourrait y
avoir un ton entre entre public sénat et
cette passerelle pour atteindre un
public qui ne vient peut-être pas
naturellement sur le canal 13 de la tnt
merci la parole est à madame nathalie
delattre
merci madame la présidente monsieur
floraux dans un contexte budgétaire
contraint comment comptez-vous mettre en
valeur à l'antenne de public sénat tous
les territoires y compris les outre-mer
et rendre compte de l'activité de
terrain des sénatrices et sénateurs dans
l'exercice de leur mandat
par ailleurs comment comptez vous
assurer l'égalité femmes hommes à
l'antenne merci merci pour votre
question effectivement je pars ma
carrière de journaliste
journaliste politique j'ai j'ai sillonné
la france en suivant des responsables
politiques en faisant du reportage et je
sais que cette emprise ce lien avec le
terrain est fondamental c'est une des
particularités de la chaîne public sénat
qui offre à la fois un traitement de
votre actualité en plateau sur des
tranches bien particulière mais
également qui permet de suivre vos
travaux dans les territoires il y a un
lien et j'en ai parlé dans mon exposé
avec les groupes de la presse
quotidienne régionale
ils produisent énormément de contenu des
vidéos d'une grande qualité et je pense
qu'il doit y avoir peut-être un
partenariat renforcé à ce sujet pour
ancrer un peu plus la présence des
territoires à l'antenne il y a ensuite
des émissions qui existent aujourd'hui
qui vous suivent dans votre quotidien et
qui viennent parfois pendant plusieurs
jours et bien comprendre les réalités
que vous rencontrez dans l'est dans les
départements concernant l'égalité hommes
femmes aujourd'hui
et bien c'est un sujet qui a été je
dirais pris en main par emmanuel kessler
ces dernières années des rendez-vous
d'information notamment à l'antenne sont
présentées par des femmes
c'est bien entendu et bien une priorité
que j'entendais poursuivre si on me
confie la la direction de l'entreprise
il y a eu une évolution sous votre
impulsion une évolution législative et
j'entends être être particulièrement et
bien à l'affût sur ce sujet sur le sujet
de la diversité également sur le sujet
de l'inclusion le handicape également
aussi merci monsieur fleurot alors je
vais poser la question suivante à ce
jour vous avez effectué l'ensemble de
votre carrière dans les chaînes
d'information pourriez vous nous
expliquer en quoi votre expérience
professionnelle vous permettrait de
présider une chaîne de service public
comme public sénat
et pensez vous que c'est la même
approche que celle des chaînes
d'information que nous devons chercher
pour public sénat sinon comment concevez
vous justement cette mue c'est vrai que
j'ai travaillé au sein de bfm tv et de
ses news donc dans un univers de des
chaînes d'information en continu et je
pense que mon expérience de journaliste
politique expérimenté est un atout pour
public sénat de comprendre les enjeux
aujourd'hui de comprendre votre
quotidien de comprendre presque de
l'intérieur en ayant suivi vos travaux
l'actualité parlementaire
je pense que dans la période qui s'ouvre
c'est nécessaire afin de porter je
dirais un projet une vision d'entreprise
pour pour public sénat et c'est
d'ailleurs une tradition que cette
chaîne soit dirigée par par un
journaliste
j'ai par ailleurs dans les
responsabilités encadrer des équipes
nombreuses parfois sur le sur le terrain
qui se déployait partout dans les
territoires
j'ai été en lien avec bien entendu
l'organisation de l'antenne et la
direction de mes entreprises pour mettre
en place des des opérations spéciales
des des dispositifs aujourd'hui je veux
passer entre guillemets une nouvelle
étape dans dans ma carrière et donc
diriger une entreprise comme public
sénat c'est c'est pour cette raison que
je suis ici devant vous vous m'avez
demandé la voilà c'est la mue entre
guillemets c'est voilà ce passage que je
souhaite que je souhaite faire très bien
merci monsieur fleurot la parole est à
monsieur joël guerriau merci vous dans
les présentes
monsieur l'euro en prenant connaissance
de vote de cette candidature j'étais
surpris agréablement surpris
d'abord parce que j'ai trouvé que la
présentation était tout à fait
intéressante et surtout parce que vous
avez là fait énormément de propositions
qui sont très bien argumenté
alors je me dis que ce long terme sur le
plan de la ligne journalistique vous
avez du contenu et vous avez une
connaissance réelle et sérieuse
la question qui m'interpelle c'est la
question de la fonction à laquelle vous
postulez qui est une fonction qui
demande ses qualités que vous avez su
nous montrer à travers cette candidature
mais aussi des qualités de gestionnaire
pourquoi parce que public sénat c'est
aussi un budget annuel de 18 millions
d'euros
et sur ce point là cette expérience ne
ressort pas de votre doigt de parcours
j'aimerais avoir votre vision sur ce qui
vous pourrez très de nature à améliorer
la gestion de public sénat
merci si pour votre question
effectivement
je n'ai pas eu la responsabilité d'un
tel budget dans ma carrière et jusqu'ici
et je mesure l'importance de cette
question
public sénat fonctionne dans un univers
budgétaire contraint en lien avec avec
vous bien entendu la dotation que vous
salou et à l'entreprise constitue
quasiment l'essentiel de ces de ses
ressources
il y à des leviers sans doute à activer
ils le sont déjà et on peut les
amplifier je pense aux partenariats au
parrainage d'émissions qui offre des
recettes
alors bien entendu la situation
économique voilà est elle aussi sous
tension et il faudra être sans doute
offensive pour nouer de nouvelles
collaborations
je pense aussi et c'est mon expérience
en chaîne d'information qui m'a apporté
sans doute et bien cette cette qualité
là ces deux d'être à l'affût de
nouvelles technologies qui nous
permettent des économies en quelque
sorte je vous ai parlé par exemple de
l'utilisation de smartphones pour filmer
des reportages c'est un outil qui
d'ailleurs est parfois et bien sans
doute plus opportun parce que moins
intrusif auprès des personnes que l'on
rencontre l'utilisation du téléphone
portable se généralise et moins coûteux
que l'achat de caméra parfois donc je
pense assez assez assez mutation je
connais effectivement cet univers
budgétaire contraint qui est celui de
public sénat
aujourd'hui mais qui est aussi celui des
chaînes dans lequel j'ai pu travailler
monsieur pierre laurin oui bonjour
monsieur fleurot dans votre projet vous
aviez vous évoquez et vous venez d'en
évoquer certaines toute une série de
pistes innovantes sur les contenus et
les partenariats
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
signature de programmes diffusés à
l'antenne de dispositifs nouveaux pour
travailler avec les jeunes publics et
parmi les pistes d'évolution vous
évoquez il ya une piste en matière de
documentaire vous avez aussi parlé de
partenariat en la manière en la matière
et vous proposer notamment d'investir le
terrain de la docu joue aussi de la docu
fiction en repensant les formes alors
que l'on constate que les mini série
rencontre un grand succès sur certaines
plateformes
est ce que vous pourriez nous en dire
plus sur cette piste innovantes que vous
souhaitez développer sans c'est vrai que
le documentaire est un format qui
rencontre un vrai succès sur l'antenne
de public sénat et certains
documentaires longs l'entrée récemment
je pense qu'il faut poursuivre cette
politique qui a été engagée en lien
notamment avec la chaîne parlementaire
assemblée nationale peut être dans une
mutualisation de coproduction ou en tous
les cas dans un agenda coordonnées de
thématiques à traiter je pense qu'il
faut effectivement suivre les évolutions
aussi de consommation de reportages
documentaires de série aussi les
français adhèrent à des séries passent
beaucoup de temps devant leur écran et
c'est vrai que les formats que l'on peut
connaître en télévision je tirais des
formats classiques 26 minutes où 52
minutes sont aujourd'hui peut-être à
revisiter sans rien retirer de la
qualité et du fond du projet il peut y
avoir aussi et bien un nouveau découpage
qui met
nouvelle forme d'écriture aussi afin de
mieux coller aux attentes des
téléspectateurs et notamment des jeunes
publics
j'ai parlé aussi de la possibilité de
mettre en preview certains programmes
afin d' événement si alizée l'antenne la
mise en ligne de certaines séries se
fait beaucoup et permet de voilà de de
toucher un autre public d'événements sia
lisez la sortie d'un document de créer
du lien avec la communauté
merci monsieur fleurot il nous reste
encore du temps puisque vous avez 40
minutes ce que je propose à mes
collègues c'est de poser peut-être une
ou deux questions complémentaires en
fonction du temps disponible monsieur
capo-canellas mais faire des sillons
merci madame la présidente monsieur flo
vous avez évoqué le salaire les
relations avec notre consoeur lcp avec
laquelle nous partageons le canal et
j'ai noté la formule mutualisation de
moyens n'est pas fusion lorsque vous ai
précisé
un petit peu ce que vous entendez par là
notamment on a un arrière-plan nous la
question que pose souvent l'assemblée ou
que la condition qu'ils nous qui nous
semble qu'elle pose c'est à dire qu'elle
a tendance à regarder la mutualisation
des moyens comme devant être à manga
bleu menthe associée à une utilisation
éditoriale est là pour le coup ça pose
le problème des spécificités de la
chaîne que nous souhaitons défendre
alors voilà qu'est ce que vous voyez là
dessus et puis deuxièmement vous avez
parlé des smartphones tout à l'heure
quelle est la limite à l'usagé des
smartphones parce que forcément il ya
des personnels qui sont aujourd'hui j'y
ai ri et pour la chaîne voilà comment
vous voyez tout ça effectivement
mutualisation des moyens c'est à dire
une collaboration dans l'achat par
exemple de matériel dans la coproduction
parfois de d'événements il y a des
rendez vous qui sont réguliers à
l'antenne qui permettent aux deux
chaînes de travailler ensemble
il peut y avoir aussi l avenir des
événements sur le terrain qui peuvent
nous permettre de travailler ensemble
public sénat et la chaîne parlementaire
assemblée nationale mais fusion des
rédactions fusion des management je
pense effectivement que ce n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour
ce n'est pas ce qui est souhaité ici
d'ailleurs et vous me l'avez tous dit
dans les échanges que j'ai pu avoir
tout simplement parce qu'il y a et on
l'a vu dans l'actualité récente une
spécificité
je dirais à vos travaux une singularité
ici public sénat a aussi un lien
particulier avec la presse quotidienne
régionale c'est un
c'est un axe très fort de développement
des programmes et et c'est ce qui
singularise je pense le l'entreprise
alors concernant l'utilisation des
smartphones moi je pense que
effectivement certains types de tournage
ne le recommande pas il faut savoir
adapter l'outil à la réalisation et il y
a
par contre des moments où l'usagé d'une
voie là d'un téléphone portable
parce qu'il est moins imposant moins
intrusif permet de deux d'aller à la
rencontre des français dans une intimité
à la rencontre des personnes que l'on
souhaite mettre à l'image
il ya une émission qui est aujourd'hui
diffusée sur l'antenne de public sénat
qui s'appelle terre à terre et qui est
tourné aussi avec des smartphones la
qualité de l'image
aujourd'hui a fait de très nets progrès
ce n'était pas le cas auparavant
et je pense bien entendu que dans une
discussion bien avec les salariés les
journaliste reporter d'imagés bien une
petit à voir
l'utilisation de ces outils merci et
monsieur hervé l'émergence présidente
vous avez évoqué la question européenne
et la question d'une une émission dédiée
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
davantage
c'est une une question auxquelles les
sénateurs au travers de leurs
délégations falloir commission même aux
affaires européennes comme au travers du
travail parlementaire lui même sont
particulièrement attachés comment vous
voyez cette émission je pense que vous
l'avez en plus rattaché un peu au
territoire est ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire davantage oui c'est vrai qu'on
aujourd'hui l'émission qui traite de
l'actualité européenne est réalisée
depuis bruxelles en plateau en
partenariat avec france 24 ce qui permet
et bien d'être en prise directe avec
cette actualité mais qui ne permet pas
de retranscrire la réalité sans doute de
l'activité européenne et de l'actualité
européenne sur les territoires dans les
départements au plus près des français
je propose effectivement une nouvelle
émission qui aborde cette question sous
cet angle là c'est à dire de quelle
façon et bien concrètement les décisions
qui peuvent être prises au niveau
européen ont des répercussions un impact
c'est pour ça que j'ai intitulé cette
émission l'europe près de près de chez
moi
je pense que ça
c'est une façon là aussi de mieux rendre
compte de cette actualité des travaux du
parlement européen de la commission
on le voit aujourd'hui à l'occasion de
la crise sanitaire l'europe bruxelles
peut sembler déconnecté des
préoccupations des français et
s'interroger avec un ancrage local sur
cette thématique là permet sans doute
permettrait sans doute voilà de
rapprocher l'institution européenne des
réalités des préoccupations des français
merci plus de questions peut-être
rapidement comme il vous reste encore un
petit moment
une petite question pour conclure
l'année 2022 va être une année
particulière pour les rédactions
pourriez vous nous dire comment vous
avez envisageriez son traitement 2022 et
est marqué par ce rendez vous avec
l'élection présidentielle auparavant il
y aura d'autres copains qui vous
concernent d'ailleurs je pense aux
régionales au départemental un
renouvellement sénatorial mois deux mois
de septembre mais c'est vrai que le
rendez-vous présidentiel sera forcément
un moment fort de l'antenne de public
sénat
j'entends d'ailleurs le vivre avec cet
angle du local du terrain des
préoccupations des français qui vont
chercher à exprimer des des envies à
exprimer des idées et à la rédaction de
public sénat d'être au plus près de 2
des français pour faire vivre justement
ce débat d'idées en lien avec vous
effectivement où il pourrait y avoir des
opérations de dialogue entre
parlementaires et les français afin et
bien justement de ceux de se démarquer
peut-être des chaînes d'information en
continu qui traiteront de cette
actualité sous un prisme plus lié au
débat de plateau je dirais public sénat
avec la chaîne parlementaire assemblée
nationale doit également se positionner
sur des rendez vous je pense aux débats
aux interviews des des candidats c'est
l'évènement marquant politique de 2022
et il faudra se positionner à ce niveau
là très bien monsieur fleurot et
maintenant il vous reste à conclure
effectivement votre intervention dans la
limite de 40 minutes qui sont impartis à
chaque candidat
vous avez la parole monsieur flamand
madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je
souhaite donc vous redire l'honneur qui
est le mien de présenter mon projet pour
public sénat je suis ici à l'issue d'un
processus de sélection ouvert
transparent qui est à l'image de ce
qu'incarne le sénat vous êtes la chambre
de l'indépendance de l'ecoute ou le
temps long des débats permet souvent
d'être en avance sur son temps la
chambre de l'équilibré des pouvoirs et
de une chambre qui est résolument proche
des français et de leur quotidien
une chambre bien en prise avec la
société
ces évolutions que vous accompagnez si
vous m'avez donné la possibilité de
défendre la vision que je porte pour
public sénat c'est justement parce que
vous jugiez sans doute qu'il y a des
choses à changer et que je peux par mon
expérience mes idées continuer à faire
grandir la chaîne qui vous représente la
faire grandir avec les équipes de public
sénat
j'y ai beaucoup réfléchi cette décision
de me présenter à la présidence de
public sénat je l'ait prise en
conscience avec modestie mais avec
beaucoup
de détermination est ce que je souhaite
vous dire c'est que je suis certes un
journaliste politique met pas un
journaliste partisans je ne serai pas le
président d'un camp mais celui qui
défend une institution la vôtre et
chacun de ses représentants dans leur
diversité
certains d'entre vous me découvre
aujourd'hui d'autres m'ont vu sur le
terrain et à l'antenne connaissent mon
engagement et ma rigueur que je souhaite
investir à 100 % pur public sénat ma
candidature au poste de président
directeur général s'inscrit dans la
tradition de cette chaîne d'avoir choisi
des journalistes pour la diriger
maîtriser les codes de l'actualité vous
connaître presque de l'intérieur pour
porter une vision éditorial adapté
particulièrement dans cette période
troublée est en effet essentiel pour une
chaîne qui fait de l'actualité politique
et parlementaire
le coeur de son antenne publique sénart
à 20 ans aujourd'hui
si la marque est bien ancrée dans
l'esprit des français
la chaîne n'a sans doute pas été
suffisamment prescriptrices des
changements ces dernières années à bfm
tv
j'ai participé à la création de la
chaîne en 2005 en étant au coeur des
mutations qui marque encore maintenant
le paysage audiovisuel et de la même
façon depuis deux ans et demi ces news
et bien j'ai vu cette chaîne qui a su
partir à la conquête d'un nouveau public
avec des débats d'opinion
il ne s'agit pas et vous l'avez compris
de copier ses chaînes d'information mais
à public sénat d'être maintenant aussi
ambitieuse en conservant sa singularité
son identité vis-à-vis de la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale avec
des programmes renouvelée en utilisant
de nouveaux outils de façon à gilles et
en repensant l'offre digitale avec une
équipe dédiée pour toucher un public
plus jeune et plus large
je m'engage à réaliser ce projet en
associant pleinement les collaborateurs
de public sénat
la rédaction ne met d'ailleurs pas
inconnu j'ai été amené à travailler avec
certains journalistes
ces chantiers seront menées en relation
approfondie avec les partenaires
historiques de la chaîne
les représentants de la presse
quotidienne régionale en particulier de
la presse spécialisée aussi des radios
et des télévisions locales
j'ai déjà pris des contacts et je sais
qu'il y a une volonté partagée d'innover
et d'aller plus loin dans l'exploration
de nouveaux champs d'expression ou de
renouer plus fortement avec la
thématique de la culture ou celle du
patrimoine par exemple public sénat et
pour tous ces acteurs soyez en persuader
une opportunité mon projet vous l'avez
compris est une promesse de confiance
confiance de public sénat
avec toutes ses parties prenantes en
indépendance mais aussi confiance pour
faire de public sénat
un acteur résolument ancré dans l'avenir
de l'audiovisuel
voilà la route que j'entends tracé je
vous remercie
[Musique]